what's up instagram amanda bynes here
my court date is coming up in two weeks
that was amanda bynes earlier this month
after she filed a petition to terminate
her conservatorship she's been living
under one for nearly nine years and now
the 35 year old actress's request has
been granted i want to thank you all so
much for your love and support
peace out
amanda's attorney confirmed the news on
tuesday telling e.t the former child
star is excited and looking forward to
living life as a private and normal
citizen the statement goes on to explain
that her parents have both been very
supportive throughout the process
amanda's attorney says the bindses have
helped her work towards a positive
transition into the real world after
living at a structured community for
women which he adds was the goal from
the beginning of the legal arrangement
quote now she's able to live on her own
independently and free of the
conservatorship amanda's conservatorship
has been handled by her mom lynn bynes
since august 2013. she has overseen her
daughter's personal and medical
decisions as well as financial affairs
tamar armanak the lawyer who represents
amanda's parents told et about the
general process of ending a
conservatorship back in 2019. there
would be a hearing a whole process it
could take as much as a week to two
weeks it's almost like a mini trial
where each side would be able to bring
in subpoena their witnesses bring in
their documents
and show and prove their case now a
source tells e.t that amanda's parents
are very happy for her excited at how
well she's doing and can't wait to see
what she does next quote they are ready
to move forward and for the
conservatorship to end as well
the conservatorship was first put into
place when amanda was 27. after she had
several run-ins with police and was
placed under an involuntary psychiatric
hold
amanda later admitted that at the time
she'd been under the influence like when
she wrote that now infamous tweet about
drake
when you told drake to murder your
vagina
i actually wasn't being insincere i was
like
saying
murder my vagina
you're serious i was serious but i was
also on drugs
so that was my way of saying like
let's do it man
but i was like on drugs and trying to be
hilarious
flash forward to last april et learned
that she was leading a quiet life living
near the beach still attending fashion
school and working toward earning her
bachelor's degree now her attorney tells
e.t she's still concentrating on school
and thinking about launching a fragrance
and clothing line
quote she is very creative so she's
trying to find an outlet for that
but will she return to acting i do miss
acting and i actually have something
surprising to tell you i'm going to
start acting again yes the hairspray
star's attorney says fans shouldn't rule
it out quote she has a new life ahead of
her and she is so young she was a great
actress i'm sure many people would love
to see her return to acting
[Music]
you